Israel and Hamas agreeing on a deal that
will free a number of hostages in Gaza
in exchange for a temporary pause in
fighting the release of hostages by
Hamas their release is part of a deal
that's been in negotiations for weeks
emerging from the darkness of captivity
carefully loaded into those Red Cross
Vehicles now undergoing the delicate
process of reuniting with their families
on November 22nd Israel and Hamas agreed
to a temporary ceasefire
this was more than 6 weeks after Hamas
militants killed over a thousand
Israelis and took roughly 240
hostages and after Israel's Relentless
bombing and ground invasion of Gaza
killed over 14,000
Palestinians under the deal Hamas would
eventually release 105 hostages mainly
women children and foreign
Nationals in turn Israel would release
240 Palestinian prisoners mainly women
children and young adults the vast
majority of whom Israel had detained
without formally charging a Bus full of
women detained by Israel until now
tearful family reunifications between a
mother and a teenage son the moment a
mother finally sees her daughter the
first time after 8 years in an Israeli
prison this exchange was a new chapter
in a long history over decades Israel
has released tens of thousands of
prisoners in exchange for hostages the
first C of Israeli soldier to be
returned home in a generation key to
that deal the simultaneous release of
the first 500 of more than a thousand
Palestinian prisoners there are more
than 7,000 Palestinians in Israeli
prisons around 8% of those prisoners are
serving life sentences for serious
crimes including killing Israeli
civilians and
soldiers but what about the rest of them
how did all of these Palestinians end up
in Israeli
prisons to get some answers we called
Hadi vbo a professor of law who
researched the Israeli prison system and
basil farage a professor who specializes
in cultural studies and research on
political
prisoners Palestinians are mostly
convicted in military courts and
Israelis are convicted in non-military
courts these are two of the main
Judicial Systems in Israel a civilian
court system and a military court system
military courts are presided by Israeli
military judges there are Israeli
military prosecutors and they operate
under Israeli military law which is very
very different to the Israeli
non-military uh legal system the scope
of each of these different court system
is determined not even by the territory
and not by the nature of the charge but
rather by who is being
prosecuted this court system mostly
stems from military orders that go back
to the beginning of the Israeli
occupation of Palestinian territories in
Israeli military and civilians have
feared violent resistance from
Palestinians so these military orders
list rules for public order and security
we're talking about thousands of
military orders that have been published
since Israel's occupation one of those
early military orders was military order
number 101 which basically prohibited
any political expression it includes
bans on Gatherings of 10 or more persons
for a matter that may be construed as
political without military approval it
also bans the display of flags or
political symbols except with a permit
and people who violate the order could
be liable for imprisonment for 10 years
or large fine or both another crucial
order is number 1651 it's a 108-page
document which Consolidated a sweeping
list of offenses including a 10-year
sentence for anyone who attempts to
influence public opinion in the region
in a manner which may harm public peace
or potential life imprisonment for any
act deemed a disturbance to the security
of the area or the IDE F the Israeli
Defense Forces which is quite vague and
that allows for ad hoc discretion by the
Israeli officials to decide what
constitutes a disturbance of the public
order here's an example of how the
orders are used in 2016 a lawyer was
detained during a peaceful demonstration
in the West Bank City of hibron that
called for reopening a main downtown
street that the Army prohibits
Palestinians from accessing one of his
charges was for demonstrating without a
permit and another for attempting to
influence public opinion in the area in
a manner that may harm public order or
safety in other recent cases Israel
charged Palestinian journalists with
incitement saying News videos they had
taken which were often of confrontations
between Palestinians and Israeli forces
political processions or funerals
constituted
incitement once arrested they often end
up as what Israel calls security
prisoners it allows for a lot of
discretion but it's overwhelmingly
applied to Palestinians the vast
majority of these security prisoners
placed in the military system are from
the West Bank and they are largely
transferred out of their territory to
one of 19 prisons within Israel and the
fact that Israel transfers Palestinians
into facilities inside Israel is widely
considered a violation of the Fourth
Geneva Convention which is a Cornerstone
of uh International humanitarian law a
smaller number of security prisoners are
also Palestinians from Gaza though they
are often sent through a different
system another small number of security
prisoners are PAL inian citizens of
Israel though for non-political crimes
Palestinian citizens of Israel are
largely sent to the civilian court
system on the other hand no matter the
crime almost all Israelis are placed in
the civilian court system so Israeli
settlers and Palestinians in the West
Bank even if they are accused of
committing the very same crime in the
same territory would go to different
courts Israelis to civilian court and
Palestinians to military Court where
from the moment they are arrested
through their detention they are
governed by a starkly different set of
laws I think it's important to emphasize
that due process is not at all present
in Israeli military courts first about a
quarter of prisoners are in what's known
as administrative detention
administrative detention is essentially
when a person is being taken to custody
incarcerated without any charge or trial
that is presented by Israel as a
preventive
measure in April of 2023 Israel was
holding over 1,000 administrative
detainees without charge that number is
up to 2,000 since October
7th they are held on secret materials
meaning Israel says they have evidence
but Palestinian prisoners have no way of
accessing the materials or knowing what
they've been accused of and every 6
months the courts can rule to extend
their detention indefinitely
Israel says it only uses administrative
detention when evidence of Acts that
endanger security cannot be presented
for reasons of confidentiality and
protection of intelligence resources it
has been used systematically uh to
criminalize Palestinian action to
criminalize Palestinian organizations to
criminalize Palestinian um human rights
work as well and also to to instill the
sense of fear that anyone who dares to
speak against the occupation could be
punished without having due process
then there are the three quarters of
prisoners accused or charged with a
crime some are serving life sentences
for serious crimes including murder and
protecting Israelis from violence is a
large part of Israel's rationale for
having this military court system in the
first place but the vast majority of
prisoners over 90% are charged with
other security
offenses aart from the charges the way
these two court systems operate is also
vastly different in the military Court
system public defenders are not
regularly provided and confessions in
military Court are often written in
Hebrew by an officer requiring many
Palestinian detainees to sign statements
or confessions they don't understand
which can then be used against them once
a Palestinian prisoner actually goes to
trial conviction rates are staggering
99.76% so essentially what that means is
that once a Palestinian is brought
before an Israeli military Court they're
as good as destined for
imprisonment in Israeli civilian courts
there's a different standard even when
it comes to what it takes to be arrested
let alone convicted when you look at
crimes against Palestinians according to
data collected by one Israeli human
rights organization of more than 1500
cases of ideologically motivated settler
crimes investigations were closed
without indictments in 93% of cases in
another of their studies of cases that
did indict Israeli suspects for violence
against Palestinians only a third of
cases resulted in full or partial
convictions they are protected by the
law we have witnessed images of settlers
burning Palestinian Villages down to the
ground and killing people they were not
persecuted or or or sent to any form of
real
punishment and there's major
discrepancies in sentencing too for
example if convicted of manslaughter a
Palestinian faces life imprisonment
while an Israeli convicted of the same
offense would serve a maximum 20 years
imprisonment in Israeli military courts
Palestinians can also be tried as adults
at just 16 years old in civilian courts
it's 18 years old since 2000 at least
13,000 Palestinian children have been
arrested these are minors between the
ages of 12 and 18 by the time the War
Began there were over 150 of them in the
military court system either placed in
detention or in Israeli prisons one
quite common charge against them is
Stone throwing there a long history of
uh Palestinian resistance through Stone
throwing for children for example
Palestinian children that is the most
common uh charge and that's an offense
that is punishable by 20 years in
prison conditions within prisons are
another issue Palestinian prisoners are
subjected to overcrowding abuse torture
repeated denial of family visits denial
of medical care and solitary confinement
and even if a prisoner dies in custody
Israel often practices is a policy of
keeping the remains of scores of
Palestinians and freezers and numbered
Graves with the end of the ceasefire
Israel's ground invasion of Gaza has
resumed and even though some prisoners
were released in exchange for some of
the hostages the population of
Palestinians and Israeli prisons has
only increased officials estimate the
number of Palestinians in Israeli
prisons has doubled since October 7th
you're talking about a place that's
occupied through military force through
Decades of Oppression of violence in
this broader context of occupation I
think the prisoners issue actually
became very Central for Palestinians so
all the different issues faced by
imprisoned Palestinians have been
heavily criticized by human rights
organizations who call on Israel to
address those the limitation of this
framing of the problem is that the focus
here is on reforming the system rather
rather than asking whether the system is
fundamentally
[Music]
flawed